in the wake of President Trump's remarks
about the events in charlottesville
eight CEOs that's a lot eight CEOs
resigned from Trump's manufacturing
Council yeah they've all cited Trump's
reluctance to condemn white nationalists
and neo-nazis as their reason for
leaving
well then earlier today Trump announced
that rather than replacing the CEOs he
was disbanding the council altogether
getting rid of them
yeah all of them yeah now most CEOs and
corporations are quickly distancing
themselves from the president however
there are still some companies sticking
by him for example there's the makers of
white in Liquid Paper
they're singing oh yeah yeah there's
yeah there's stink-eye oh underarm
deodorant for neo
there's marching through Poland spring
water which is really yeah there's
masterrace saxophone reads those are the
best saxophone reeds that one's just a
stupid one folks don't worry about it
there's the pro core goose step climber
let's say get in shape the old-fashioned
way this almost a surprise Kashi and no
idea why cause she's sticking with it oh
my god
no there's no joke there and then
finally KKK mark is sticking with
himself
[Applause]
you